we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P here is a caller who's
upset
that I didn't end up reviewing the my
pillow pillows and that it was Pat who
did David it's Allen from Jersey I'm
watching the bonus show yeah you know
the bonus show where all you want to do
is make money but everybody else that
makes money is bad oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad exactly
and you promised us that you would
review pillows yes now Mike pillow broke
his promise because he never sent you
the pillows until you finally shamed him
into sending you the pillows okay fine
he broke his promise but eventually he
did send you the pillows but you broke
your promise for you promised to review
the pillows not not send your soy boy
Packer review the pillows right no you
promised to review the pillows and fine
okay Pat you know you're too busy you
know Mr big shot David Patrick review
pillows so you sent your silly voice had
to refuse them but Pat didn't even
review them Pat said he tried the pills
for 20 minutes and debug no that's not a
review okay listen guys this isn't a
pillow show so they didn't send me the
pillows then they offered to because
they heard I was telling people pillow
didn't send me the pillows I told Pat
quite frankly I've got enough pillows
and I've got a lot on my plate Pat tried
the pillows he couldn't even fall asleep
so yes after 20 minutes he bailed and
switched back to his normal pillows that
is the review we were able to do sir I
apologize with tears in my eyes if you
want to see Pat's review of my pillow
pillows
um it's on the bonus show earlier this
week we've got a great bonus show for
you today we'll talk about the border
wall we'll talk about Elon musk's
censoring speech on Twitter could it be
we will talk about a call to end Georgia
runoff elections and so much more sign
up at joinpakman.com